he's Michael Wilbon and one of the stars
that pardon me interruption and great to
have him back on the program good
morning Mike how are you good how are
you I'm good what's on your mind like
what what is going to be the topic
tonight on pardon the interruption in
your goodness I guess we're going to
start with last night's football game
and win of the Packers and is there more
drama and stress between Aaron Rodgers
and his rookie coach Matt Lafleur I
guess we'll start there that seems a
pretty good place to start with those
two teams now do you guys argue discuss
what should be the number one topic like
how often does that happen
oh really early because but you know
what though Dan I'm gonna say that you
know this because you're putting your
own show together every day I'm gonna
say 70% of the time then well maybe I'll
maybe it was more like 50 to 60 the the
number was where the lead story presents
itself and you shouldn't have to do too
much digging to figure out the lead
story sadly for the last like month has
been way too much Antonio Brown but I
think I think I don't know close to 60%
of the time or more it presents itself
there and there's the mornings where I
will call in and say hey we we should be
late but but really and by the time I
think especially by the time we get
rating on the air at 5:30 Eastern the
the top story or the top two and then
we're splitting it between one and two
and presented themselves pretty well by
where does pass interference show up on
the rundown today you guys gonna be on
the rundown and you know some of it some
of these things will be and how tired
are you already of that thing and
passing affairs not tired of it yet it's
like why is the league so afraid of
acknowledging what's obviously passed
that's why why is the league so afraid
of that clear and unmistakable what's
clearly unmistakable to me I guess is
not to the league or to its zebras or to
its television
buthe people I'm not sure about that but
you know some of these some of the
topics when you get tired of them like
Antonio Brown I think I said the other
day we're at the point now where
producers and editors and every workshop
ought to justify having Antonia Brown on
the rundown and I just have it
automatically to justify it because at
some point is not news
it just is clean and but we're I don't
think it's a culture anymore we're
capable of really being discerning and
talking abut is really news and what is
it everything is not relevant everything
is not important but we missed that yeah
and that could happen with anything
including pasture defense but we're not
there yet
it feels also different or interesting
that the Eagles feel better at 2 & 2
then the Packers do at 3 & 1
yeah maybe because of the injuries
because they were still missing DeSean
Jackson even though they had a Shawn
Jeffery back and they're going to Road
and sort of save a game like that the
Panthers also easily could be 2 & 2 that
coming from the Chicago and depicts the
Bears really blew it on that opening
Thursday night but you know the the the
Eagles I thought you needed if we played
that game with me that last night's game
or I think it was the Eagles and I think
that's the reason why that people will
feel better about that in Philadelphia
that deep sigh of relief we're coming do
you find yourself looking at Aaron
Rodgers with his body motion if you know
whenever he's on the sidelines with his
coach like are you are you paying more
attention to it then you ever have this
year or is it about the same no it's
about the same and partially Dan because
he I'm just down NFL head coaching in
general what is it down on it I mean
everybody makes everything so
complicated they want to make it so
difficult so I guess in some ways prove
their own genius
I would rather if I was a Green Bay
Packer I rather Aaron Rodgers be calling
all the plays another thing he always
gets it right but I trusted Aaron
more than I would a rookie head coach
and I and I actually you could
substitute that sentence for a lot of
different people not too long ago I
looked up just sort of the roster of
coaches and who was coaching head
coaches in 1985 in the NFL and head
coaches today all right to me the
disparity is numbing and yes you can say
that different pressures operating on
today's cozy
you know God now don't get the you know
second and third chances that a coach
would you know thirty five years ago all
that may be true but I just look at the
head coaching now I look at some of
these games and decisions that are made
decisions are made even through the week
and I trust Aaron Rodgers more than I do
met with learn yeah you can substitute
any number of names in there from Matt
Lafleur I want to just sound like I'm
picking on him but I watch the Packers
last night and some of those early
things I just I
my feeling is whether he's on the
sidelines or on in the game that Aaron
Rodgers is rolling his eyes sometimes
and I would trust him I'm trusting him
more we're talking to Michael Wilbon
co-host of pardon the interruption I
mentioned when Rex Ryan said that Baker
Mayfield was overrated as hell I said
okay I know in this hot take industry
that we have now that that'll get lost
in actually what he said after he said
he was overrated as hell and I thought
that Rex as a defensive minded head
coach is probably pretty accurate with
what he sees with Baker Mayfield now Rex
knows nothing about you know coaching
offense but he does know coaching
defense and I thought the overrated his
hell was just it was clickbait but then
you know maybe what was lost in the
context of that was he was assessing
Baker Mayfield from a defensive
perspective and I do trust his judgment
on that what did you take away from that
quote by Rex
I think he's overrated as hell at this
point I mean Baker Mayfield hadn't done
anything I mean I'm pretty decent up
here last year for instance Dan the the
other night and the Sunday night game
where Mayfield can't do anything with a
little
football after he's headed two and a
half seconds I've been led to believe
and by the way overrated doesn't mean
that Baker Mayfield had fought for
anything it means that he's been rated
too highly by others and everybody every
analyst every former player employed by
every Network including mine I haven't
railing about this for a month all the
entire offseason they all want to talk
Cleveland into being a good team yeah
that's what good Baker may feel not just
part of it he's the lead of it yeah we
want that story that's why I said that
we wanted too much I don't have them
making the playoffs and then either
crouches and all that I mean but no I'm
with you you can't talk the browser to
being good they got to play their way
into being good and Baker Mayfield who
can't make a play when he's got the ball
two and a half seconds were we led to
believe he was such a great athlete that
with his legs and in mind he could
create he was gonna be Aaron Rodgers no
he's not he's overrated as hell right
now
maybe he'll grow into that statement not
being the case I suspect he might but
why don't why does everybody have to you
know this is a grade school you don't
get extra credit you got to earn this
and he hasn't heard anything yet he's
overrated but also we're the ones that
create this week we over age you and
then we we scream that you're overrated
when Baker Mayfield didn't over ate
himself to Jersey I don't have a real
feeling of empathy for Baker me I know
but okay let's say like Lamar Jackson
everybody had their opinion he's just a
running quarterback then he comes out
and plays well as a passer and then you
know where we're the ones that labeled
him or other guys did hey he can't play
can't stay in the pocket all these
things then it comes out and he plays
well and then we're like well you know
give him credit like maybe he is that
maybe he is better like I I get the
feeling I can't wait for this narrative
on Monday Mike if Lamar Jackson out
plays Baker Mayfield then then it's
gonna be the Browns made a mistake they
should have taken the decisions the
declaration oh yes yes I just proposed
you know what Dan as much as I love
watching NFL football if I went out I
got one of those one of the first people
getting a dish a direct and DirecTV so I
could have Sunday Ticket long before
there was the red zone I I mean I did
this in the mid-1990s when it first came
out cuz I love watching pro football and
in a way it sort of gets ruined for me
now because of just what you're saying
so now I just wanted to watch it at
games and it's like really do I need the
other stuff because it's gonna make me
angry the declarations now over you know
the over statements on Monday just drive
me crazy you're right I totally agree
with you and and I why do I have to be
careful I don't know about how you
handle this I I don't want to root
against the guys who've been overrated
because it's not really their fault yeah
and I gotta be killed by that with
Cleveland but God the Browns one where
enemy number one for me for week one I
just couldn't wait for them because I
just didn't think they were any good and
didn't justify any of the hype that was
heaped upon them during the entire from
February first people were telling us I
said the Browns you mean they didn't get
a buy-in you would have thought they
would have had a by opening weekend just
because the speaking overrated
underrated your your network the
mothership came out when its top 100
basketball players yeah yeah yeah and
you know LeBrons not number one so that
you gotta have a hot take about LeBron's
not number one but I found it amusing
that you have people who are paid
professionals who were upset that Zion
Williamson was ranked higher than klay
Thompson and I said well if you pay
close enough attention you'll realize
Kevin Durant's not even on the list and
Klay Thompson's not playing until March
that's why it's like on is ranked higher
than klay Thompson right now when clay
comes back or has a full season he'll be
one of the top 15 players in the NBA you
would think that's why people are so up
like a Zion Williams and you know he's
overhyped here and I went okay might be
but this has nothing to do with Zion and
has everything to do with klay Thompson
Divac available dan I didn't have an
issue with or take even on LeBron being
number three I'm like okay
I mean he's you know he's not what he
was ten years ago he's not know and I'm
okay of Kawhi Leonard or I I'm not gonna
be okay of Anza kumbayas number one I
just simple shouldn't be raised a head
to me a Kawhi Leonard base what we just
saw but I add some others though and I
went a little crazy on draymond Green
being 38 and Trey young being 28 because
and people of course we're so slavery
ously devoted and stupidly sowed in
numbers analytics because on what
playground if you were playing for
something significant would you take
Trey young over draymond Green if you
would
you're an idiot sound like our friend
Charles now died you would idiot you
always did a good job but did you know
did you know
like John Collins I think is one of the
top 50 players yeah in the world I'll
bet you 99% of the people who are NBA
fans couldn't tell you who played I mean
I'm glad you got some recognition yeah
I'm all I'm good with that but you know
I look at these lists and I don't know
if LeBron goes man I'm gonna prove it to
people this year I'm number one I got it
I don't know if it matters well okay I
don't think it enters LeBron at this
point of his life but I've been the
person I've mentioned draymond Green you
don't think that is enough being named
to an all-star teams you don't think the
dream out as a guy gives because he's in
the prime of his career and you've got
guys like even porzingis porzingis Susan
never want to playoff game I don't think
he's been in a playoff game hasn't even
played two years he's ranked like 14
spot no four spots above dream on and I
think dream on bite and I don't know
this too haven't talked to him in this
case about this I imagine
yesterday when I was looking at that
list and the dream on would be a
goddesses really and it was just there
are people there are athletes there are
all-time great athletes who yes they can
sort of summon up
some extra steam for being I know for
dealing with slights real or perceived
LeBron no I don't think he's one of
those guys I bet you there's some guys
on that list who are I'll leave you with
this we had Chris Mannix on last hour
and he shocked me he said he thinks the
odds of the Lakers winning the
championship should be less than the
odds of the Lakers not making the
playoffs how about that one on that but
because I don't I'm not buying the
Lakers win the championship either I
don't even have the Lakers in my top
three and maybe not my top four and I
finally do it put it together
efficiently well he said you got join
Howard and a new coach and yeah I agree
it's a lot to put Dan is a lot I mean
there's a lot they got going on let's
say the Clippers don't have going on or
Utah doesn't have going on or Denver and
I still think difference a little too
green doesn't have going on Portland
Portland and so land it's a lot the
Lakers have and Dwight Howard is that
sort of gave me the sour milk look on my
face too but I but I'm not going to miss
the playoffs I think the Lakers will be
in the thick of something you know maybe
playing for home court and they're gonna
be a fascinating watch I think so much
more than these other times where we
thought they were going to be and they
haven't been but yeah and what happens
is the other thing what happens is
LeBron who's down what is 17th year and
I came around the 17 I think I think so
so LeBron gets another one of these
early season boo-boos and he's of course
he's gonna be out longer at year 17
because he's not indestructible not
anymore then he would have been in five
years ago what happened to then with the
Lakers and no I know who's my out
already they got a lot but I man I'm
still not going lower than like fifth or
he can maybe talk me into sixth one I
don't have him have a home court in the
first you know first to start the
playoffs I don't
what if LeBron won another title and did
it with a third team he should just walk
off okay but would you can we do we have
a different conversation about his
greatness overall greatness compared to
Michael Jordan it's different greatness
different different but no no me to me
Jordan is out of his reach but it's not
you know it's like if Mike Tyson had I
don't know knocked out Buster Douglas a
couple other people will either
approached Ali no no but we will be
talking about his greatest different way
I agree with you there Dan but and you
can then marvel at LeBron in an entirely
different way but there's - I got too
many other I go back to that whole thing
about the playground
you know if you viewed a game and you
were playing for your life when a minute
left in a game who's getting the ball
the Bronner Michael my I mean I asked
this to people in Cleveland when I want
them to just shut up and possible LeBron
hater I don't just like LeBron I had
mine on the bottom I'm a LeBron fan yeah
but it's like don't just don't go there
with Jordan on me otherwise I just pull
up the single question a minute left
what do you want I see guys just look
down and go thank you thank you Mike
dan you're good to talk to you buddy
thank you it's Michael Wilbon co-host
part in the interruption for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on be our
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]